Truth is like,
hey guys,
good morning.
How is everybody?
I'm assuming all the giddiness is
for me, right? Because that's, Huh.
Very,
very excited to have you two here.
So many of us have either
read the book or saw the film.
We had a screening last night,
but for those of us in the audience,
or maybe who will be watching
the recording later and
who haven't seen the film
with book, Do you want guys want to
give us a brief synopsis of the film?
Sure. Why not? Uh, it's, um, uh,
it's about a Asian American professor,
a complaint by Constance Woo.
Uh, and, uh, she's teaching at
Nyu and she is dating this guy,
uh, Nick Young, uh, who and
who gets invited to, uh,
his best friend's wedding and
Singapore and he invites her along.
What she doesn't know is that he's
the richest from the richest family in
Singapore.
So all his ex's socialites,
family members are out to
destroy this American girl.
So, uh, it's, it's a fun, fun romp,
but has some, uh, I think some,
a deeper cultural messages within at all.
Yeah. And so let's take
anti a little bit. Um,
so this film is an all Asian
cast and, um, you know,
here at Google week we've talked about
is this is the first Hollywood film with
an all Asian cast in 25 years. The last
one being the joy luck club in 1993. So,
um, what are your thoughts about the
significance of this film coming out?
You know,
in 2018
I think it's beyond the right time.
It's, it's too late, if anything.
Um,
John's been a bastion for,
for Asians all around the
world and I think now is,
is, is a, is the correct time
for this. And um, you know,
when we were creating and, and, and
sort of putting together the film,
he literally scoured the earth for
the correct actors for each role.
And those actors were, were Asians from
America, from the UK, from Australia,
from Malaysia and Singapore.
Um,
and to hear the stories of how important
this project was to them really
resonated throughout the
entire costs and crew.
We knew there was something
special about this, but we,
we didn't feel too much
pressure because we were such,
so in the moment that we were,
it was,
it was such a joyous kind of experience
being the show of all being the star of
our insurer. Um, previous to this,
a lot of the roles in Hollywood where a
sideline does as the lecture characters,
no one with a, with a
particular voice. Um,
but this time everybody had their moment
to shine and damn. Did they deliver?
Yeah, we've got fantastic costs.
Comedians who just, Aquafina
is hilarious. Can Job Jimmy. Oui,
Ronnie Chang because Santas,
um, so it was, you know,
it was,
it was something very special for us.
Yeah. And um, so recently an article
came out in the Hollywood reporter,
um, and um, I think, um, John, you,
you were in the, in the article, but
there it seems like in back in 2016,
there was a big decision to be made.
Um, you guys had competing offers,
you had an offer from Warner brothers,
a studio,
and then you also had an offer
from Netflix. Um, which would have,
would have given you guys a big payday.
Can you walk us through why you decided
to go with Warner Bros and what was the
significance of putting this
felled on the big screen?
Yeah. Well, when we started,
when I started the movie,
um, only a few years ago,
it was, um, you know,
we didn't know if it would ever
get set up at a big studio.
It had not been done for so long.
Um,
there wasn't some gigantic star that
could like push it through. Um, and,
uh, and so we developed it on
our own. I brought in Adel Lim,
who's a Malaysian American
writer who I'd worked with on a,
on a pilot. We got into, into shape that
I thought was a really great shape. And,
um, then we went out to the studios
and what we found was of course,
Netflix, uh, they have a lot of money and
know how to throw their weight around.
And, uh, and I love Netflix, doesn't,
there's nothing wrong with that. Um,
I just felt like, um, and Kevin and
I, and our producer's credit to them,
deferred to Kevin and I
to make that decision.
We had 15 minutes to make this decision.
A Warner brothers was going to pull
the offer in 15 minutes. So, uh,
they didn't even make, they said we were
going to give you, I know this pastors,
um, uh, they said they were
going to make the offer in the,
we had 15 minutes to decide.
Uh, so, uh, we had like 21,
like different lawyers, agents,
everyone there and our, and our,
and our producers defer to Kevin and I,
and Kevin and I had talked kind of the
night before and had to like a heart to
heart about like, why
are we doing this? What,
what brought us together and what we
realized and we knew might come down to
money.
We didn't come.
We didn't know it was gonna come down
to that big of a gap of money. Uh,
so it's a little harder. I kept thinking
in my back yard, could use a Redo.
I could use that new thing. Uh, I'm
still thinking about it right now.
Um, but, but it came
down to, you know what,
it's important for Hollywood studios to
put a movie like this on the big screen
because it sends a message,
it sends a message across the world.
It's still cinema, it's
still cinema. And it says,
when you put a piece in the museum,
it anoints it as special annoyance.
It as something worth your time and
energy. You have to leave your house, pay,
go fight with parking, pay for
the ticket, pay for your food,
jumped into a dark room,
turn off the license.
They told me a great story and
I think that energy, um, is,
is saying you were worth your time.
Um,
and I think subliminally that means so
much and it trickles to all media at that
point. And we knew we were in a
position, we didn't need money.
I'd done enough films.
He had done enough that everyone
had done enough stuff here.
No one was desperate. And so
if anyone was do it, we could,
we actually thought maybe we donate a
percentage of the Netflix money to great
causes for Asian American.
And then it was like, no,
it's all trying to trickle down to
this moment right here. So, uh, yeah,
I had sweat things that I
never knew I could sweat.
But it actually really helped us.
And ultimately like when you double down,
triple down on something like that,
it makes everybody more invested.
And now it was on us two pressure Warner
brothers to publicize it the right way
to market it the right way and credit to
Warner brothers they have come through
in,
in spades.
And I think the important thing is, you
know, not just telling the story of the,
um, of the Asian American story as well,
but you know, growing up in the u s so,
you know, not that many films portraying
Asians, even on television, you know,
constants is in fresh off the
boat was just, um, you know,
a sitcom with featuring a full
Asian cast. And so, um, John,
you had a great quote in that article and,
um,
I just want to share
with the group, um, you,
you said you wanted to do a film in a
way we haven't ever seen Asians before.
Contemporary, stylish at the top of
art and fashion. Emotional, funny,
sarcastic, unapologetic, confident.
Why do you think there aren't more
films portraying Asians like that today?
I honestly don't know. This is the world
we live in. These are the people I know.
These are the people I've interacted with,
both here in Hong Kong and
Singapore and Taiwan. So, uh,
I guess I didn't even realize myself
that people didn't see this because I
already had seen all of it. So, uh,
I think it was when I was showing
people my pitch and showing my friends,
they're like, Whoa, I didn't know this
existed. I didn't know this music existed.
I didn't know they could be,
could dress so cool. And I'm like,
what are you talking
about? They, uh, so, uh,
so I think it was more of like,
it was so obvious and I think we all
a lot of us know this world. And then,
and then also,
but through the,
through talking to Henry and meeting all
these other agents from all around the
words,
which I did not know,
I didn't even know Ronnie Chang who's
on the daily show lived in Australia was
what was it straight. I just saw him
as the guy on the daily show. Um,
learning about their experiences was
a huge learning experience for me and
opened my brain a lot.
I didn't know a lot about Singapore either
before jumping into the movie. So, um,
yeah,
I think it was just a,
a matter of sharing what we already
know and hopefully that cracks the door.
Cause I'm sure there was other things
that I don't know that we don't know,
but people have great stories in history
that just haven't been shown in the
light.
Um, so Henry, um,
there's been some controversy around
the casting of your role and, um,
it's led to a dialogue of what it means
to be Asian enough to be cast in this
film.
And he said in an interview with instyle,
there should be a conversation
about it. And, um,
I think we should be educating people.
What sort,
what sort of education do we
need to do about this topic?
Yeah. You know, we talked so
distinctly about black culture,
Asian culture,
Latino culture,
but there's nothing
that is being discussed
about mixed race people and
how they can own the, um,
their ethnicity. Uh, and so we, we,
we sort of fall in this limbo where when
we try to speak up, they're like, no, no,
no, no, you're not Asian enough
or you're not white enough.
I was never wide enough for the UK. I was
never very good enough for a Singapore,
Malaysia.
Uh,
but I sure as hell wasn't going to let
that put me down and not have the ability
to own and be proud of my heritage.
Um, so I did that very young.
Um, and so I've been finding out my entire
life. So when that, when that came up,
but it wasn't a surprise. It was,
it was just a, another thing.
But at this point we have the platform
to be able to discuss these issues.
Um, you know, talking about
Asian rights, it's, its,
its rights in general.
It's about being, um,
Portuguese mixed with Malaysian.
Like in Malaysia, in Singapore,
there's so much mixed heritage from
the Portuguese, the Spanish, the Dutch,
um,
all integrating into culture.
So why can't we be proud of that and why
can't we own that as a badge of pride?
Um, so for me, um,
I knew through and through that I
was the right person for the job.
There was no question about that.
I was more Asian than,
than I can possibly
describe. Um, and, and,
and John John,
John,
John saw that and I was the
right fit for the character.
They had extensive searches
for every single person.
That's why the costume was so good.
They wanted to find those voices that
could bring these characters to life.
And I think people get confused.
I think they think the movie takes
place in China or something and cause,
cause Singapore,
it has like so many different and
this and he's all mixed together. Um,
and the character nick had to
have been educated in the UK.
So like when you're looking for
is very specific. One I was very,
very sure of Rachel.
I wanted her to be Chinese American
because in that, in the movie she, uh,
in the script she talks specifically
about Chinese culture and specifically
about what she wants to be. So that was
a very thing. But for nick it was like,
especially talking to Kevin
and his real history, he was,
this is all sort of based around his
life. When you find someone, uh, like,
like Henry Golding,
it's that perfectly.
And we searched all around the world
and of course he ended up being in the
exact place of the book, told us he
would be, he was living in Singapore.
We could have saved a lot of
money. And uh, so anyway, yeah,
when someone's perfectly, well,
I think when you watch the movie,
all that bullshit argument goes out
the window. And originally Henry,
I think you were hosts on
BBC and you weren't acting.
So did it take some convincing for
you to like audition for this role?
It took a lot of convincing.
Um,
I had been a presenter for travel shows
and news channels for a good eight,
seven, eight years. Um,
so I was kinda stuck in that
mindset of being stomped and,
and kind of could into this category
of this is your lane, the sticks where,
because you're not going to
be great at anything else.
That's some of our problems is
that we limit ourselves. Um,
and the,
the auditions came around and was huge
sort of noise in Singapore and Malaysia.
So much excitement for this movie that,
that John was attached to it.
Warner brothers had bought these riots,
they had such faith faith in this book.
Um, and a couple of couple of
emails came through as well,
do you want to audition for this role?
And I was like, ah, I'm not an actor.
I'm not right for this. There's
somebody out there who deserves this,
who's worked hard, um, who's
going to represent the, uh,
this community or represent actors in
general for this really pivotal role.
Um, and it wasn't until, uh,
a mutual friend Steve Jang
and here in San Francisco, uh,
put us together.
It was our mutual friend on Facebook
that was cyber stalking. John went
through my Instagram, he went pretty deep,
slid into my dms,
pretty much trying not to like anything
too fast so that he couldn't see that I
how deep I was married.
But uh,
but he,
he got in touch and we had this amazing
hour long conversation and he was in la.
I was in Singapore and we spoke about
what it meant to have grown up in,
in, in all different sort of
Asian environments. Him In,
in Los Altos here in Los Angeles,
San Francisco,
myself
in Malaysia on the east coast.
And um, he, he, he was like,
I've got two questions, you know, can,
can you act and will you read for me?
And at this point I was like,
there's this,
everything is pointing towards this
moment and it's, it's ridiculous.
If I do not just switch that,
that mindset and,
and throw myself into this.
It's crazy if I don't. Um,
and then we went on to the
audition process and now
my life has completely done
a one 80, and I think it's going to
be doing some somersaults person.
And what I love about Henry too is like
my big brother, I'm the youngest of five.
So my big brother, he's like six, two
good looking, athletic, all the opposite,
right?
And
I showed him the movie and when Henry
comes out in his white suit attire,
so park and it's like this beautiful shot
of through the bushes and he's coming
out, my brother starts crying, which I'd
never seen him cry. He's not that type.
He's like, you have no idea. All
the years have I felt so, um,
so different than anyone else
and not seen as as this symbol.
And so Henry represents
this to so many, uh, uh,
at least for Asian men I know,
and myself included,
to see someone that is an
aspiration and inspiration and,
and everything in between.
A total gentleman of someone
from like another Arrow,
a movie star, another era. And
you could be in any ethnicity,
doesn't matter like Henry was.
It has,
it has this star quality that
makes you want to be a better man.
And I think that that,
yeah.
Will you marry me is what I'm saying?
Um, yeah, so in the film, piglet has
a wonderful line like Damn Rachel,
it was like the Asian bachelor
and as a fan of the bachelor,
many amazing life. Yeah. Best lines
a lot that didn't make the car too dirty.
Sure.
So, um, with the cats, it's pretty
national. International, you have English,
American, Malaysian. Um, so Henry,
you're both Malaysian and English. Um,
what was the experience like working,
um,
working in Great Britain are different
or similar to like Asian Americans in
Hollywood or Malaysians in Asia?
Yeah. You know, in, um, in the
UK when you're labeled as Asian,
your South Asian, nothing wrong
with that. It's just that,
that is for some crazy
reason. That's a, it's you're,
you're either of Pakistani or Indian
descent, um, and that's Asian in the UK.
So I was always sort of Chinese or,
or something weird like that.
Um, but they, but over in America,
when you're Asian, you're, you're,
you're of East Asian, the
set. And so for myself,
it was,
it's really interesting to,
to have had the group of
such international sort of
be people who, like I said,
we're, we're swapping these
stories of how they struggled, um,
in the different areas in comedy, in, in,
in sort of the acting and
the odds. Michelle Yeoh, uh,
for instance had a completely different
story to tell. She grew up in Malaysia,
in Malaysia, but she was in the Hong
Kong industry for the longest time.
And there's no lack of representation
there because it is a Chinese market and
it's, it's the Chinese demographic. So,
uh, John always brings up, like when,
when they were first told me,
she was like,
I don't know what you guys are talking
about. The cinema is great for us,
but that's because it's, it's
so different, but on, on,
uh, on, on sort of Western,
um, media, uh, representation
is a big problem. Um,
so that was, was sort of an
exchange of, of learning for us. Um,
so I think we all grew such a broader
perspective and I think that's something
that the film really promotes is the fact
that you can be of any Asian descent,
any, any different ethnicity to, to the
one that you've been adopted in, in,
in this, in a particular country.
Um, be able to be proud of it,
be able to speak your thoughts,
be able to make your own mind
up if of who you want to be,
where you want it to go.
Um, and so hopefully this,
this just triggers more conversation.
Uh,
it triggers more avenue for expression.
So I don't know if everyone in the
audience knows, but father, um,
is the famous chef chew and his restaurant
is a landmark in silicon valley.
You guys structure here.
Um,
so questions.
What were your parents like?
Were they very traditional?
Do they expect you to take
over the family business?
What did they think when you
went to USC to study film?
Um, they're both traditional and
very, not traditional. I mean,
we were in a Chinese restaurant.
They came to the states not knowing a
word of English and started this business
and 50 years later, it's still
there. Uh, and they always,
they actually never let us
work in the restaurant though.
They always said do everything we couldn't
do. So they put us, I took drums, sax,
Violin, piano, guitar. I was
in like tap dance classes.
We took etiquette classes.
My mom really thought we were going to
be like the Kennedys, so she dressed us.
She dressed us the same.
We took ballroom dance classes,
we went to shows in the city every
weekend, whether it was opera season,
ballet season, uh, our musical
season. So we had a very different,
uh, bringing in that way. But my,
my father was very
traditionally Chinese to, uh,
didn't want us to drink soda at dim
sum table and things like that. Um,
so I had these two different things.
My mom was like,
go pursue your passions,
just be happy. Um,
and my dad and my mom
also at the same time,
it would be like about family first
and sacrifice yourself for family.
So I'm like, what the hell? I don't know.
What to do. I'm so stuck. And that's,
that's actually a big theme in this movie
of an Asian American going to Asia for
the first time and going through this
culture identity. I remember being scared,
going to school that people that I would
smell like Chinese food or that my food,
that my parents packed me,
the dumplings I've been playing with,
like smell up the room.
Um,
and one day on Chinese New Year,
my parents came and did a presentation
for our like second grade class and they
brought the lion dancers and they brought
a red envelopes for all the kids and
chocolate gold cup. And I became
like the most popular kid in school.
And it was the first time I was
like, oh, I'm proud to be as,
and then we went to the restaurant
every time after like sports games or
whatever, everyone wanted the food. It
was, it was through to their hearts,
through the food really. And so,
um, uh, to do a movie about it,
which I also never did a movie about
my own culture. I then it was always,
you know, you don't want it if
you're the only Asian in the room,
you don't want to just do the Asian thing.
Cause I feel like everyone then marks
you as that and just silly thing.
But it's a reality that you
feel. Um, and a certain point,
I think online when everyone was
reacting to the whitewashed out movement,
all that stuff, it made me realize
that, oh no, I earned the spot.
I don't have to apologize for my spot.
I can explore these things as an artist,
as a filmmaker, the way every other
artists gets to do that. Um, and uh,
and look, people are showing
up for it. It's a, it's a,
it's an a very empowering
feeling when you see the result.
And this was not guaranteed to have people
come out to see the support the other
end.
So
it means a lot.
Um, so we have one more.
When we had our press tour,
the restaurant yesterday, it
comes full circle. It was amazing.
Uh, his dad went out to the car
or the brought out family photos.
Oh,
they took them all off the wall,
put them in the trunk so they could
show the reporters. They took my awards,
they put them on the
tables of the restaurants.
These were her words when he was
like seven years old. It's true,
isn't it? 100%. You're cute.
So we organize a Google,
um, family dinner.
The restaurant is your dad fly your
words again? Guaranteed. All right.
I have told them not to for many
times and then, okay. All right.
We might have to organize that later.
Um,
so we're going to do one more question
here and then we're going to open up to
the audience. So if you guys
have any questions, please
line up at the mic. So, um,
similar, um, question for you
Henry. Um, kind of about your,
your upbringing in your career
and how your family concerned it.
Cause you kind of had a shift in cry.
I think your eyes are red
on your trained hairdresser.
I was a half size for a long time.
And then you became a presenter on
BBC and now you're an actor. So how,
how did your family, you know, I think
about this transition and careers,
you know, they're there, they've
always been very open. Um,
and if you consider sort
of back in their day,
mixed race couples weren't
overly accepted. Um,
so for them they've always had a
very open mind about most things. Um,
so for from what they taught us, it was,
it was mainly, you know, be good to,
to others, um, try to sort of, uh,
promote kind of a wellbeing and in,
in terms of,
of helping others and, um, don't
do any, anything stupid and, and,
and be safe. Those were the rules. So
when I, when I told him one day, I,
I want us to be a chef, they're
like, okay, great. Do the chef thing.
I did the chef thing for about a week,
gave up and then I became a
hairdresser and they're like, amazing,
like go do that, follow your passion. Um,
and so it was a half size for four or
five years. As soon as I finished school.
Is it true that all the old ladies would
want to make appointments with you?
So you can say, I have to
do so many, so many pounds,
my hands like
bleeding. Um, so, but then,
but then I, I was like,
I'm going to be,
I'm leaving the UK,
I'm going to move back to
Malaysia and Singapore.
I wanna I want to find myself there and
I want to get into this amazing industry.
Um, and, and they were like,
absolutely just, just, just be goods.
It can be good to people and um,
and just stay safe. And that was,
that was them sending me
off. Um, so it's, you know,
it's having this sort of movie,
just really drill home, kind of the
aspect of family, the aspect of,
um, identity. It's, it's been warming
cause you, you look onto yourself,
you know, it almost sweet. It
sparks something within all
of us. Uh, we never were
always sort of going forwards.
We never consider the traditions
of family or traditions of culture.
Um, sometimes it's nice to look
back and appreciate all of that.
And as of like yesterday,
his parents weren't coming to the
premiere and we're like, dude,
you got to get them to the premiere.
I don't think they understand what
this is or you got to force them.
Your job is to get them there.
And so now they're going to show up.
So I think they're in for a whirlwind
of a day. It's be pretty crazy for it.
Um, okay. So why don't we
move to audience questions
first one honey. Sounds good. Hi,
I'm Connie. Uh, ever since Constance,
we're starting to becoming like a thing.
I'm thinking about going back constants
cause I feel like it's a cooler, Nina,
so you can tell her that. But
I was wondering, um, John,
you kind of touched on this earlier,
but I was wondering for both of you, um,
how is it shifting from me,
uh, environment where I'm not,
everyone was Asian and everyone's from
diverse backgrounds to moving, um,
to a team where most of the
cast and crew were Asian.
Were there any you'd like
expected or didn't expect?
Um, I mean, I've made movies
overseas before in London
for now. You see me and, um,
it's always a little cultural shock as a
person just going over there and living
there for nine months or so. Uh,
this one was our most global, uh,
crew.
I think they were also during Ramadan.
So we had to their
fasting at the same time.
So I was learning about our crew.
It's like a circus. So you, you,
you have these very intimate moments
with people you don't know yet.
And it's very quick.
But we became a family.
We knew that they couldn't eat
till whatever time. So everyone,
we had to pace them and then,
and then other people were bringing
things to the table that you didn't know.
Styles and things that since
we're shooting in Singapore,
in Malaysia about Singapore
being educated about, you know,
wealth here isn't about size
even though we know they,
you think Vegas and big columns and big
doors, uh, Singapore and the small island.
So like a $20 million place
looks like a small apartment.
But actually it's worth a lot.
Things like that.
Cultural things that I had
to learn, not just from our
crew, from our, our cast. Um,
it was a, a, you know what I love
about making movies? Everyone asks me,
what's that one movie you're going to make
that will make, you know, that's when,
you know, you made it. I don't have that.
When we had movies or something that
feels like an exercise for me, a breed,
I need to do it. It's like breathing. Um,
and this was another one of those ones
that like sort of transitioned me into,
uh, into a different part of my life
where I got to learn a lot from them. Um,
so hopefully you feel that in
the movie when you walk in,
you get to go through the same
journey that I did. In a way
I wanted to start by saying that this
is like a really important movie for
people.
Uh,
this one of the first movies search
humanizing Asians in North America.
I say North America because I'm Canadian.
MMM.
On that note, like I look to hear more
about casting decisions of the movie.
Like Henry,
you mentioned that this film allows you
to own your Asian heritage and you know,
everyone in this room is really how
people that I don't like mean to take away
from that at all.
Like I grew up also in a mixed household,
but I do want to hear like Urin John's
thoughts that there is discussion within
our community that the
main male lead is not,
not a complete representation
of what Asian men look like.
And casting like a lead with mixed western
and Asian features might perpetuate
stereotypes of how Asian,
like really Asian looking men still can't
be romantic leads even in movies that
representative.
Well I think one thing,
I had a lot of discussions about this.
I think what it's great to
have a discussion what a
privilege to actually have a
discussion about casting
Asians as leads a um,
and um,
and what I found was it's one we've found
the perfect person to play this role
isn't a very specific movie
about Singapore with a
person from Singapore and was
living in this life and has a
British accent and was all that,
all those things that aside,
I don't blame people.
At first I was angry at people
for saying these things.
Is Barack Obama not black enough?
Is Halle Berry not black enough?
Like why do other people get why? Why
do other people get the okay and so, um,
but I actually, I don't,
I blame the system itself.
I blame that when you've been hit in
the face 20 times and then someone comes
over and tries to give you five and you
duck in and jab them in the abdomen.
It's whose fault is that?
It's not the person who's been
victimized over and over again. I,
I know that feeling. I've
been there. Um, it's, it's,
it's whatever this environment that
we've created and it's a shame that one
movie is supposed to define
everybody's experienced.
That's just an unfair idea.
Um, and, uh, so, so I don't,
I have no ill will about,
and I think it's a very healthy discussion
that we should have and it's nice to
have. Um, there's other
discussions like, can you,
can you hire a Japanese person to
play a Chinese person and vice versa.
And Meryl Streep can play any ethnicity.
So why do we have to say that
this is whatever. I Dunno. Um,
so I think it's just a discussion that
we have to make the decision on our own
for, and my hope is that this
movie, um, because we have,
it's a book, so it has very defined
characters and we cast accordingly.
We saw so many thousands of people all
around the world. And I had to, uh,
there are people that I could not hire
that were great, um, uh, for roles, uh,
but not in this movie because they don't,
we just don't have them.
We only have a certain amount. So I hope
that this actually gives more movies,
opportunities to get out there. Cause I
think that's the bigger picture. Um, uh,
what's the Bruce Lee about? A
line about when you're, when you,
when there's a finger pointing to the
moon, don't focus on the finger. Um,
focus on the, the enormity of
this moon that we're headed
towards. And I think, um,
we want other filmmakers and other writers
to be telling great stories so we can
broaden this out.
And there's not just one character
we're looking on and be like, well,
why doesn't that represent all everybody?
Um,
so that's what we hope and
that's why when see you guys,
when I meet the journalist that we've
met in the past where we would go to
youtube and see all the
youtubers and all these creators,
it gives me a lot of hope because they
are writing the stories and coming up
with the things and having the expertise,
uh, to, to expand this dialogue.
Um, and, and yes, let's have the dial.
Let's go. This is, this is great. Um,
but at the same time, let's
focus on the bigger, on the,
on the bigger destination that
we're headed towards. Terrific.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Hi. So I think you started touching on
some of this a little bit when you talked
about can't, you know, represent all
of Asian American, this one film. Um,
I do want to have you expand
a little bit more on that.
So it's clear that the film holds
important significance and, um,
it's really momentous for the
Asian community. Um, there
are, of course, you know,
criticisms around the film not actually
being representative enough of the vast
diversity that exists in Asian America
today. Um, some of sad, you know,
it perpetuates the model
minority in some ways,
which is a damaging stereotype
for the Asian community.
And some of sad, you know,
like you said,
this is one step closer to where we
want to be and where we want to go. Um,
so just want to hear a little bit more
about your thoughts on that and how, um,
how you might respond
to some of those ideas.
Well,
my first thing is watch the movie and
then maybe make a opinion about it.
I'm mostly,
people have not watched the movie.
Maybe they read the book and
which has very specific things,
but that's not the movie. Um, and
then when we watched the movie,
then let's have a conversation and
listen, this is, this is the point of, of,
of movies is to have a conversation.
When I watched joy luck club,
my dad got us all into a van.
We didn't know what movie you were
watching forces to go into this theater at
the earliest showing 10 in the morning.
Right.
Save the money,
I'll discount,
give us some afterwards.
And we loved it so much.
We were quoting things from it cause
we're like, oh, that's like our auntie.
I'm not your Auntie.
She says certain things
that we like and um,
and for you,
and we had like a three hour conversation
and that's what the power of movies
and um,
you know,
obviously the d that didn't open up
everything for all Asians at that point.
It was a success. And I think for
us it gave us this, this light, um,
and uh,
uh,
but hopefully this starts conversation
that can create other work.
Like I sort of said before that that will,
um, that will create the platform that,
that we need. This is again, not just
a movie. We would keep saying this,
this is a movement.
Um,
and maybe that's a little self serving
because we have a movie that we're
releasing,
but the reality is that's where we are.
That's what Hollywood is going to
be watching that opening weekend.
If people don't show up
that opening weekend,
it's going to be many years before the
guys, we're going to still fight for it.
Don't get me wrong,
but it's just,
this could be a really nice
jolts to get us jumpstarted.
There's four projects at
least in Hollywood right now
that are ready on the line
and they have not greenlit and waiting
to see how this one does and in a lot of
more stars other than this guy and
other than this guy to actually, um,
get out there to the world. I just want
to add on to that also is that, um,
you know,
a lot of people are concentrating
on the Asian American view.
There's a lot more Asians out there in
the world who don't live in America who
face the same exact challenges,
uh,
voices in the Philippines,
Indonesia, Vietnam, Thailand. Um,
but people seem to be thinking that
the only Western Asians are American.
Um, so it's the voices like
Michelle's, uh, like myself,
like Ronnie Chang is from Malaysia is
Roger Whole, um, jinx from Shanghai.
Um, those, uh, tales that
should be told in other movies.
It's it what, what John said, it is unfair
to have though the weight of the world,
the weight of, um, Asians in general on,
on this one particular mood
on this one particular movie.
It's like having the
world balanced on a pin.
There's so much to tell and
so many unique cultural,
culturally significant stories
to expand people's horizons,
expand beyond that of just being American,
Asian,
being a American Filipino
American tie. Um, you know, it's,
it's, it's stunning. W we're, we're
opening, we're cracking that door open.
We're hoping that not only
filmmakers but reporters, reviewers,
people in all sorts of industry
step up and be proud of,
of writing stories no
matter what Asian ethnicity,
even if it's not Asian American.
Um,
and so we need to look at the broader
picture and, and, and, you know,
there's no label for, for just being
Asian as many subcategories and,
um, you know, like how can we just have
the love that you see in the movie,
you know, that that is the
true translation of everything
we're trying to do is,
is that story of coming together,
fighting adversity.
And we find it together as the only
way we're going to win. Thank you.
Okay. Um, we have one more last
audience question. Okay. Thank you. Hi,
I'm Kat John. I'm a fellow bay or
native. You don't have to tell you.
I watched never say number twice.
Nice believer, believer. I see you.
And growing up I was told by my family to,
you know,
pursue a medical position when I got to
college or like pursue a tech position.
But I've always had creative interests.
And for both of you,
what advice do you have for
someone, especially with my
background, our heritage,
to really just break out of that sort
of internal pressure to really pursue
those endeavors. And specifically for
Henry, do you feel like in your next role,
do you feel pressured to choose a
character that breaks the common Asian
stereotypes?
Okay.
Uh, uh, Constance, uh,
who was with us yesterday,
she had to go back to shoot her show.
Said something great to when someone
asks a very similar kind, she said,
uh,
you don't have to listen to your parents.
I'll tell my mom that.
I guess that's as simple as that.
I know it's hard and a,
you have to figure out how
to do that. But, um, um,
the reality is I think we're in and, uh,
yeah, I mean that's, that's growing up.
That's uh, uh, that's saying,
yeah, we're good enough and,
and you don't have to have the baggage
that your parents may have from a,
from another era and another time. Um,
men, women, young people, whatever class,
whenever it doesn't matter, um, we
can, we can determine our own destiny.
And now if you're a creator, if
you're a writer, if you're a director,
my advice is always, if you're a director,
you've got to direct. If you're ready,
you've got to right.
There's no excuse you.
Nobody has to give you permission to that.
You can borrow a,
a phone camera from somebody
you can edit on your phone.
You can get it on online and get it to
people. Um, if you are a storyteller,
you tell stories and that's just
innately in you and you do it.
It's like being an entrepreneur.
You can't train someone.
They're either starting a
business or they're not.
You can't aspire to be an entrepreneur,
uh, for myself. Uh, you're talking about
my, my next roles and things like that.
And for me it was, it's really, you
know, being, uh, an Asian lead in,
in, in a particularly Asian
movie. I'm super proud of that.
But my real goal was the normalization
of being a different face in,
in this big sort of industry of Hollywood.
Um,
and normalizing the fact
that it's an Asian lead, uh,
that it's not a particular role
that's written for an Asian character.
My next film is called a symbol favor.
I played Blake Lively's husbands
Adda Kendrick's love interest.
Um,
my name is Sean Townsend.
There's no, there's no, it's not
necessary to explain my ethnicity.
That's where we need to get to.
Uh,
we need to get normalize this fact that
we have all these beautiful Asian faces
on the screen and not have to explain
where they've come from or what they're
doing there. Um, and so that's the
level that we want to. So for me,
I just want to be a leading man in these
amazing movies and spread inspiration
to people who think that they're not
good enough, that they, that they,
because they were born somewhere else,
that they don't belong in,
in the country that they are
in now. Um, so I think, um,
you know,
I'm going to be tracking away at that,
but that doesn't mean that I'm not
going to be taking Asian roles.
My third movie,
I was playing an Asian in that and that
was playing a gay Asian or that I'm
super proud of that. And it's, it's,
it's, it doesn't matter the sexual,
it doesn't matter the race.
Um,
I just want to be a spokesperson
or a role model for,
for people who felt like
they didn't have that choice.
So they can't aspire to be
something great. Preach. Thank you.
Today if you guys,
um, haven't seen the film, I highly
encourage it. I saw last night, loved it.
So be sure to go opening weekend
and support the film. I'm sure you,
you guys would appreciate that.
Tell your friends or your family.
It's a great movie. Um, and with that,
I know you guys have a packed schedule,
need to be on your way. So thank
you so much for visiting your call.
Sure.